en la universidad de oxford aquí en
inglaterra donde se desarrolló la vacuna
astrazéneca contra el cob y 19 los
ministros de salud del g7 buscan
alternativas soluciones para acabar con
esta pandemia y también alternativas
para acelerar el acceso a las vacunas de
los países en desarrollo a través del
mecanismo
kóvacs pero también se espera que firmen
acuerdos en cooperación científica que
permita identificar las alertas
tempranas que eviten una nueva y una
futura pandemia o pandemias provenientes
de animales antes de que traspase en la
barrera de los seres humanos y también
del ambiente esta cumbre que culminará
mañana es la preparatoria abona el
camino para la cumbre de mandatarios del
g7 que se reunirán por primera vez en
dos años la próxima semana aquí en el
reino unido-